[Music]
while successfully up in the ante year
after year as far as things like drama
and action go
the historical production has also left
a host of other interesting facts and
tidbits in his wake as it's gone about
making its own spot in television
history
this is the untold truth of vikings
we're used to watching lots and lots of
vikings at this point so it might
surprise you that the show was
originally only supposed to run for
mere nine episodes a link that the new
york times deemed ambitious
we're all fated to die on a certain day
yes
the mini-series which aired in 2013 came
on the heels of history channel's
three-part hit
hatfields and mccoy's starring kevin
costner and bill paxton among others
it brought narrative drama and star
power to a network that typically aimed
for documentaries and reality tv shows
while not perfect hatfields and mccoy
showed the network that there could be a
significant interest in other dramatized
mini-series
equipped with this knowledge and with a
younger male action-oriented gaming
crowd largely in mind history decided to
head out in their long ships in search
of their bigger fish
the result vikings though there is a
ragnar lothbrok recorded in history he's
also recorded as having lived multiple
lives
the tale of the 9th century exploits
stretch all over northern europe from
multiple invasions of east anglia
during which he was killed by being
thrown into a snake pit to adventures as
the king of denmark that include the
battle with the holy roman emperor
charlemagne it's a bit confusing which
is why it's the perfect stumping ground
for a historically dramatized show
nothing is more factually forgiving than
a lack of information
part of the issue revolves around a
severe lack of primary sources
a chronic issue of the region's history
but that makes it easy for the producers
to change
things around slightly like the fact
that on the show ragnar is the king of
norway
rather than denmark as the original
story goes but whatever
it's close enough odin gave his eye
to acquire knowledge
i would give far more most of our
information on the vikings
actually comes from the perspective of
the victims we do have a handful of
other scandinavian myths that have been
passed down through the ages
and help round out the picture a little
bit like the god infused elder edda
and the heroic volsunga saga perhaps
viking's unheralded success can be
partly attributed to the luck of the
irish since a large portion of the
filming is done in ireland the island of
destiny has also been home to numerous
other big budget productions such as
game of thrones and braveheart
vikings has definitely made the most of
the lush and just plain gorgeous
landscapes that the island nation offers
many of the scenes of ragnar and his
loyal followers setting out on their
long ship for example
are actually filmed on a man-made lake
nestled in the wicklow mountains from
scandinavia to england to france
most of the sites depicted in vikings
ultimately traced their origins to the
emerald isle
even the epic scenes involving the
medieval paris are actually filmed on
the river boing with the city simply
filled in
via cgi afterward catherine winick plays
lagartha
a shield maiden who's never afraid to
step in the fray a strong
independent woman who doesn't take any
crap from her husband the character
offers a reasonably accurate reflection
of the history the show draws on for
inspiration
especially when compared to the rest of
the male dominated medieval world
and i have dreamed of taking back my
home
i've dreamed it for a long time winnick
definitely looks the part but it isn't
just her blonde locks and believably
viking demeanor that make her a great
fit for lagatha
just as important she's a martial arts
expert and we mean that
literally when it holds a third degree
black belt in taekwondo
and a second-degree black belt in karate
as if that wasn't impressive enough
she also founded and owned three
different martial arts schools
by the age of 21 no wonder those action
sequences seem to come to her so
naturally
travis fimmel who plays the dominant
power-hungry lead role
may have a few things in common with his
on-screen counterpart but they're
actually
totally different before he was known as
a viking warlord
fimmel became famous for causing
accidents as an underwear model the
actor's life has been marked by a
meteoric rise from his humble beginnings
growing up on a dairy farm in australia
but it wasn't a seamless transition to
acting fame
yeah i'm a little farm boy i love all
that little running around
and having fun you know filmore took a
bit of a detour when he stumbled onto a
different sort of stardom in the early
2000s as a calvin klein model he
reportedly made enough of an impression
on an early billboard that an uptick of
car accidents was reported after it went
up
that's pretty flattering but thummel
doesn't seem to have loved the gobs of
attention he got over his physique
eventually withdrawing into private life
before re-entering the spotlight as an
actor
another fascinating but subtle truth to
the show involves the languages being
spoken or sometimes gutterly grumbled on
the set
those aren't just strange words their
ancient language is being brought back
to life
viki's producers have brought in experts
to resurrect languages like old norse
anglo-saxon and even olo franconian the
man responsible for the delivery of
these tongues is paul mulcelides
an irish-born voice actor proficient in
countless european accents he's been
involved in many other productions
including the tudors and reign and is
the established linguistic authority on
the viking set
that doesn't mean mussolini's works
alone the lines are written for the
script and then translated by linguistic
historians before mussolini's takes them
to the actors and works with them to
ensure that their pronunciations are
correct they each have a week to learn
their lines and it's a hard and fast
rule that there can be no last-minute
rewriting that will require going
through the whole process all over again
the folks at the history channel took a
gamble on a historically based drama
with vikings
and it paid off big time with that
success still going full throttle it's
officially graduated to the next level
of cultural impact
being adapted into books and video games
multiple comic books have been written
around characters based directly from
those from the show
in addition to the graphic novels mgm
interactive and fifth planet games
announced in 2017
that they were teaming up to release a
player versus player mobile game that
would be based on the series
it's got to be a rule out there
somewhere that you can't truly claim
cinematic fame
until someone's created a game with your
face in it the guards are having a good
time with me today
the cast of vikings has arrived when
vikings was just getting off the ground
there were some actors who specifically
auditioned for various roles
to only end up playing someone else
clive standin for example
eventually ended up taking the role of
ragnar's jealous muscle-bound brother
rolo but he originally auditioned for
the role of ragnar lockworth himself
stanton explained to collider that he
was initially asked to read for the part
of ragnar but when the decision was made
to go with travis filmo instead he
happily accepted the role of rolo
a character he actually preferred to
play as it turns out
fimmel who's found enormous popularity
playing ragnar
actually started by auditioning for
floki played by the talented gustav
skarsgard
i actually wanted to play floki
originally but the
ghost stuff was already carved and he
did they did it way better than i could
ever do
clearly this is one case when casting
directors could see something the actors
didn't and all of these seasons later
it's hard to argue with their decision
in the fourth season of vikings the show
got an extra boost of star power when
major league baseball player josh
donaldson dropped in for a cameo
appearance
a big fan of the show the bringer of
reign got to do what most people dream
of
getting dressed up as a viking and
actually getting on the set in front of
the camera
this is something that i've always
wanted to do
[Music]
this isn't the only side gig for the
busy mlb star as donaldson has also
shown interest in a part-time
mma career in his free time most
professional athletes have a good
portion of their year that could be
categorized as down time and it seems
that donaldson
just doesn't know how to sit still
perhaps we're witnessing the blooming of
an acting career that started in a
dugout or maybe
we're just seeing another facet of an
endless entertaining world of rabid
fandom either way the guest appearance
was definitely a hit
the show has always had a very
uncomfortable way of getting under
viewers skin
but before the narrative driven violence
and gore even has a chance to begin
upsetting people's
stomachs the discomfort kicks off in
each episode with a haunting opening
theme
it isn't just a way to be kind of
morbidly artistic the sequence
actually has some original viking
inspiration it's based on an old
scandinavian folktale that tells of nine
sisters the goddesses of the waves who
are known to pluck vikings right out of
their vessels
and draw them to a sensual grey creepy
yes
fitting for the show about warriors
obsessed with honor violence pleasure
and untimely death absolutely when it
comes to vikings the wealth isn't
actually in the ships it's behind the
scenes many shows boast impressive
budgets and some projects like
amazon's lord of the rings series are
positively swimming in cash but a
showboat vikings produced by the history
channel
let's just say the series didn't
initially scream big budget
do you know of it why are you so certain
that it's a land of
great riches well that's apparently not
what the exact said history thought
they seemed to have signed up hook line
and longboat right from square one
in fact the first season alone was
reportedly infused with a staggering 40
million dollar budget
that's a serious chunk of change
especially for a show with few
recognizable actors that was originally
supposed to be a quick mini-series about
seafaring raiders
considering the sustained run of
popularity and overall success that
vikings has managed to maintain
however it appears that exec saw
something early and decided to steer
into the skid with everything they had
and for that we're all thankful when
vikings is brought up it inevitably
conjures an image of a bearded ragnar
lothbra plotting leading raids
and vying for power in one way or
another of course lothbrok's story ended
with his execution by means of a snake
pit midway through season four
and the show had to leave him to
valhalla as it moved on with his
bickering sons
i shall not enter odin's hole with fear
interestingly enough it wasn't just
ragnar who got bit by some snakes on
that fateful day
turns out that fimmel felt some teeth as
well when he was asked if he had qualms
about working with snakes in his final
hours as ragnar the actor shrugged off
the question with an initial
not really before following it up with
the statement that
i was covered in snake poop at the end i
got bitten a few times but i was fine it
was them pooping on me that annoyed me
more than anything
you know an actor was cut out to portray
a fearsome warlord when they choose to
criticize
snake excrement over a snake bite dudes
with swords
excessive violence and obsession with
treasures and power we're talking about
game of thrones here right
vikings has hit its fair share of
comparisons but one of the most
persistent is the question of whether it
holds
up when compared to hbo's game of
thrones after all
the two series aired concurrently and
simultaneously portrayed power-hungry
families duking it out for dictorio
authority in medieval
northern european themed settings
shouldn't they be compared not if one
viking actor has
anything to say about it climb standing
pointed out how he disapproves of his
show being compared to its high fantasy
counterpart
sure there are similarities but standing
makes the point that it's comparing uber
violence
ultra bloody apples and oranges he
argues that game of thrones is fantasy
and can lean on elements like dragons
while vikings is tethered at least
tenuously to reality and a hardline
historical narrative
considering the significant limitations
that this imposes on the show
it really does seem unfair to contrast
it to a fictional epic
not that we're comparing check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]